[Music]  kendall Jenner reflects on her total  transformation from tomboy to supermodel  a full dream come true I really did not  expect me anytime in the near future to  ever be wearing this robe and be in this  room she's come a long way from duking  it out with sister Kylie on Keeping Up  with the Kardashians  [Music]  [Music]  Kindle who is now queen of the catwalk  also opened up to love magazine about  why she took a brief break from modeling  quote last season I didn't do any shows  I was on the verge of a mental breakdown  don't cry the 22 year old has been open  about her struggles with anxiety you  have designers that have already booked  you and are counting on you to show up  I'm just telling you I think that my  health is a big deal  [Music]